good
Oh morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast after another
treacherous weekend of living in America
welcome back to the morning toast how's
everyone doing I'm doing okay I just
feel like this weekend was like really
weird do you know I mean like personally
or just for the whole work well I
thought it was just personally but the
world as well but like I just had like a
weird vibe in my like soul this whole
weekend and I said Tibet I'm like do you
feel weird he was like yeah interested
do you feel weird and I said yeah well
we all felt weird I guess I know
something was off with the world the
chakra I felt that way Saturday night
when we all attempted to go to dinner
and it was a big fat failure I just want
to say like I I I don't really um I'm
not really happy about the fact that
hibachi like was a trend because it's
like obviously over now I mean now it's
like a novelty thing that Benihana like
the only hibachi place in the world and
it's the most mismanaged dirty
restaurant and I'm really upset about it
because we went and I was like so
excited all day about Betty I was so
excited all day like and it was a late
reservation so I didn't have dinner and
I got there and I was like ready to
stuff my face yeah and it just never
happened we didn't wind up sitting there
and we minutes and then when we were out
to get seated like the table was just
like so filthy and like it was just it
was like I can really eat anything like
I'm not easily grossed out but like I
actually couldn't eat there yes so we
went hang out Italian which I don't know
I love Italian but I was so not feeling
it you know I wasn't feeling the Italian
either I like actually went to Italian
restaurant and ordered salmon which like
in my Olivia that's the same very
strange it was disgusting
hey Snitch how are you good how are you
I was here weekend we saw you went to a
country club I went to a country club
and we have to join one I know we this
happens every summer
this happens every weekend we get on
FaceTime and we try and like make these
grandiose plans where we like get a buy
a house and we join a country club
well we actually made really good
strides last summer to make this summer
the best it could be and we were denied
from our country club of choice like I
can't even imagine why and then we just
let it fall through the cracks but we
really should have just picked another
Country Club like one with good food
good pool and like cute life cars how
does the country club would you
recommend it
oh I mean it was divine like we what do
we we okay should I give you the whole
yes yes so we play
tennis which was lovely how were you at
tennis I was much better than I remember
met remember and Nicole's like you're
actually gonna actually go yeah I guess
I know how to play what we know we just
rallied we're not like being so to lose
our competitive here yeah and then we
went to the pool which was you know
lovely there are like crazy tennis girl
Sione I mean like when you were in camp
and stuff or like growing up at a
country club like there were girls who
competitive but like if you're
competitive at tennis like you're a
[ __ ] nutjob you know ball
accidentally went on the other person's
court and the man was so mad at new
tennis girls are nuts
yeah but we all grew up playing tennis
technically we are those tennis girls
but were like they were doubles partners
we could not be stopped her was the
power and me with the consistency like
those were our strengths I'm Olivia was
the power Serena and Venus check it
Olivia was the power but I feel like she
made you run around the court yeah
no but like I no matter where the ball
goes down the court I will get it back
it's I'm the best shot but I won't get
it back right and then when she gets it
it's a slam times at home you were an
unstoppable force yet happen I don't
know we moved that's when we just like
gave up on all but I just think a
country club would be good for our
athleticism all tennis skills our
appetites our skin we'd be so tan mm-hmm
I just I can't believe summer's gone by
and we didn't do it I know and like
which I mean deserves better but what
they left for chairman we had we have to
go to he's no no he's a doctor
right maybe there was a dog doctor on
the premises they would allow for other
dogs to come speaking of a doctor I have
to tell you what happened I mean I did
tell you what happened but it's just so
crazy cuz like when doctors get sick
it's like who takes care of them and
Thea was just been this like this leader
in our family like he's just he takes
care of us he's a doctor but he's also
like an emotional support animal like he
really has been like the he does it all
he's leaning in right and so what
happens when when the dogs in trouble
when the doctors in trouble yesterday so
I know what happened it's really like
it's it's it's hard for me to talk about
because I can't
first of all what happened was so crazy
and they're like my reaction like I'm so
disappointed in myself so me been anthea
went to the dog park yesterday again
until true the weekend was weird like a
my house that I went to the park it was
so [ __ ] hot we get to the park and
there's no dogs in the park I'm like we
just walked all the way over here for no
dogs so we throw a ball we're hanging
around but like maybe some dogs will
come these two little dogs come they
literally like we're like like not to be
mean all children are beautiful but like
they were so ugly and I was like the oh
you can't play with them then this other
dog came perfect Theo sighs black I
don't know what kind of dog but like
perfect size for Thea and me and ped sit
on the bench for watching the two dogs
playing and and the two dogs are playing
right in front of us and all of a sudden
the other dog literally mounts Theo from
the back puts his paws on him like so
hard starts humping and then his [ __ ]
enormous penis comes out like I have
seen okay so like dogs penises are like
tucked away but when they get like hard
I guess like they come out of their
shell so I just seen Theo's penis come
out like four times in my life and it
was literally one ride another day yeah
and it comes out like two inches it
looks like a crayon it's like a fire red
rocket yeah I like I've never seen it in
action because Theo is neutered yeah and
he just doesn't [ __ ] like he's you know
he's cool but he's trying fun he's
trying but he's been true he's been
trained and he doesn't [ __ ] so I was
shipped to my absolute [ __ ] Corte sea
six inches of dog penis try to enter
Theo and in the moment I was sitting on
the bench I was completely paralyzed
like frozen I I was just so in shock
that this was happening to my son right
in front of me Ben has such great
reflexes respect no [ __ ] respect Ben
has such great reflexes like hopped up
was literally tearing the dog's part the
dog had such a firm grip on Theo Ben was
literally I thought Ben was gonna get
hurt and like bit this was like an
episode of like I don't know black
mirror fine finally the black dog owners
mom came and was like whatever his name
was
Zion let's go and it was obviously this
was like a regular occurrence for the
lady because she took the dog to the
corner and like Pino like punished him
and then left like she was like up
another dog des ruines at the part
because my dog can't stop humping
everyone and Theo let out like a little
Yelp I was I was so disappointing to
myself for like not having better
flexes like this is my son he's in
danger I'm like I'm freezing you're
watching it happen I'm watching it
happen like and Ben was yelling at me
like afterwards that my reflexes are so
off like what are we gonna do we have
kids and honestly he was totally right
and it was just like the whole day was
ruined Theo was just [ __ ] traumatized
and we had to go home like what what
kind of world is this that's crazy I'm
so sorry for him does he have pts scenes
for sure but Theo is Theo's gay so like
this like honestly he should have been
like down but it is obvious that he
wasn't connecting with his job like why
not and it's like consent is everything
and honestly no means so I couldn't
believe it
that's really sad it was agreeing my
whole [ __ ] day and all I keep
thinking is like that mental picture of
Theo just like looking at me and I
couldn't do anything well maybe this was
like this the scare that you needed yeah
but thank God nothing happened I didn't
know like I literally was like looking
at the u.s. potholed like literally with
a microscope like I didn't know if they
were I didn't I don't know if anything
actually like went in I just I'm really
upset about it I'm sorry that's all I
should say about that okay well we're
thinking of you at this time he's at
home relaxing he's done so much you need
a bed rest he took some doggie xanax and
he's gonna be okay yeah well I feel as
though it might be time really I don't
okay what else do you wanna I just can't
believe we're like sitting here you know
doing the show when the last time we
were here like we delivered the most
piece of premium the most premium piece
of content ever made on the Internet
I know anything like how do you come
back from that I think for me personally
if we've had some hilarious moments on
the show that is my number one moment
like I have watched it now 40 times like
on my TV every single time I'll act like
I find something new to laughs without
each time and I can't imagine a world
where I watch that video and don't laugh
no it is so fun I can't imagine a person
who sees that video for the first time
and doesn't laugh if you're listening as
a podcast and you haven't been able to
catch last Friday's episode make sure to
watch it on YouTube because there's a
little special bonus footage at the end
yeah it's premium so how was your
weekend with your song out oh my god you
know it was so great I literally spent
the entire weekend refreshing our iTunes
and I still was on the top 100 as of
last night which is so nice like you
just I expected it to fall right off and
I've been just getting really positive
feedback from it people dancing to it
people's husbands dancing to
Jamie Lynn Spears shared it like so many
people really just came out and
supported the song that really made me
feel so good I'm so happy in me to such
a being I'm so glad that we have it for
posterity no I know like what should we
do with the next music video okay
no I feel as though now I feel as though
we are ready and you know we can always
dip in and out of course so without
further ado it is time for the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite toast but before
we do that I would be absolutely miss
heartbroken and devastated if I didn't
let you know that today's episode is
brought to you by article looking to
elevate your home style but feeling it
hemmed in by small square footage
articles beautiful modern furniture
helps you make a big design impact even
within a small footprint at article comm
and you never have to compromise on
great style as New Yorkers with tiny
apartments articles mentality of keeping
small apartments in mind makes me feel
good because like I love shopping online
for furniture but it's like they don't
think of me know any of people with
palaces like a ranch yeah no I never
feel tension on a hill right where the
memories will always keep you really
have a room for their memory right it's
like I don't even have room for my son
okay so articles constantly keeping us
in mind it's the easiest way to buy a
beautiful modern furniture they cut out
the middleman to directly sell you the
goods and they keep prices super low no
showroom no salespeople no retail
markups savings of up to 30% on
traditional prices focus on quality and
construction beautifully crafted
contemporary pieces up their prices and
they stay really well because I've had a
piece of theirs for maybe a year now and
it doesn't have so much as a scuff a
stain nothing and I use it pretty
it's an ottoman I use it pretty
frequently and I have other Ottomans in
my house that like Pheo what like jumps
all over and they're trash now ya know
it's a great ottoman article is offering
our listeners $50 off their first
purchase of $100 or more to claim visit
article dot-com slash toasts go to
article calm slash to us in the discount
will be automatically applied at check
out that's article a RT icle dot-com
slash toasts
toas t to get $50 off your first
purchase of $100 or more highly
recommend this brand found out about
them through the toast and honestly just
another one of the toast brands that are
improving my life and in every day basis
love it love it okay first story is from
a very legitimate news source called the
morning toasters Facebook group oh yeah
great
is Tyler C from The Bachelorette and
gigi hadid were spotted out and about at
so house in Brooklyn also known as Dumbo
house so we broke the story and now
everyone's copying it and literally no
one is giving us credit but I have to
give credit to the toaster who gave a
toast in the Facebook group it has just
been such a journey like I've literally
been watching her Instagram refreshing
every 5 seconds we got 3,000 followers I
say like what a day what a day and this
is so shocking because we also called it
because we also broke the news that they
follow started following each other on
Instagram like two weeks ago but then a
whole wrench was started our plans
because that after the final rose it
looked like him and Hannah Mike might be
rekindling they were paparazzi leaving
her apartment in the night I really
thought that was definitely like a
staged paparazzi thing because like why
would the paparazzi be waiting outside
the bachelorettes house like they're not
that mean I'm sure it's a rentals yeah
oh yeah so no it was just to stage like
the The Bachelor people get paparazzi
when they do press but they're not
followed around waiting outside their
house no so I really do want to get our
resident experts opinion on this but I
did watch episode 1 of The Bachelorette
this weekend I was gonna watch the whole
season and shockingly like I thought I
was gonna my biggest regret was gonna be
that I didn't watch it sooner people
keep saying it's like the best season
ever I knew so I was good I thought I
was gonna be pissed like oh [ __ ] I
should have watched it actually and so
we could have talked about on the show
but it took me like four hours to get
through the first episode the first
episodes always the truth so
uninterested and I and I I really do
love her and she has great guys
great-looking whatever I'm just for some
reason I'm out maybe if I stuck with it
by episode 8 I would care but like it's
my weekend I don't want to spend it
watching [ __ ] I don't want to watch
especially because now paradise is back
so like we already have to do it during
the week why we're in your weekends -
Mondays and Tuesdays you're kidding me
mm-hmm every oh my god I was literally
just about to say like you guys want to
watch together tonight but like I don't
know if I can that's that's such an
unreasonable ask like I'm sorry okay but
paradise is much better
paradise is much better I've been
watching love island it took about 15
episodes for it to get good but now I'm
there and the thing about love island
and paradise could learn something from
them it's filmed in real time so that
they're on the island now they put the
episodes out Big Brother yeah like that
day or the day after
and it's every night of the week and
like so it's overall about three weeks
of watching but I'm really enjoying
watching it every night like it's the
subject matter is not stimulating enough
you're the wait a whole week like what
is kareo gonna do yeah no it's like
three months watching once a week of
something that happened six months ago
it's there two weeks it's so
uninteresting he's so uninteresting and
I think that now you live in a world now
that like that can't survive like we are
- like - yes we're right it's at that
size right do you know how [ __ ] fast
they go like a charm paradise is already
the slow-ass five it's it's an old model
and they really it would be so much
better it's at the very least Amazon
five makes a week like let's get it out
seriously doing three months of a show
that took place over the course of two
weeks is insane so it's two hours twice
a week that's nucking futs
or they could do one hour every like
I've Monday through Thursday that would
be no because I'm really liking this
love island for me let's just like easy
to watch it's there every night for me
and it's not like this suspenseful thing
where I'm waiting on nothing okay well I
was planning on watching it I'll start I
don't know if I'm gonna last but you
guys wanna watch together sure maybe oh
I just like I just like want to watch my
apartment cuz I'm by the time it's a
game by the super [ __ ] 10:00 p.m. and
I'm at your house server all right come
I give up sex I've so many sacks I'm
gonna clean your house you can order
food for us no she's not a true host no
not like our descendents party counts Oh
oh yeah where the TV didn't work we'll
get to that we're gonna recap the
descendents three trilogy yeah they're
coming to an end
um okay but back to Tyler Sea and Gigi
I'm just like loving the sentiment
around this like not that the world
hates Gigi but it's like that's a nation
it's a GG that you would literally have
everything in the world fed to you on a
silver spoon like you just grew up being
the daughter of Yolanda - you like how
lucky are you
you just prance into becoming the
world's biggest supermodel like you have
everything in the world literally all we
have is the baths are like get away you
think I don't know on the one hand you
know I'm I want to blame Wells and Sarah
Hyland for making this acceptable for
like when they did it it wasn't in a way
because you want to know why Tyler see
is like the dream man of bachelor nation
like yeah he's like our fantasy right
was like the nerdy friend no one was
like daydreaming over marrying Wellesley
they just love team like a friend that's
how like he weirdly got into this
position where he was the bartender like
he's just make this really friendly cool
guy so when that happened we were like
kind of happy for them you know but like
this is like it's not there know it's
not fair but meaning like I don't know
what happened with Gigi and Zayn I'm
assuming they're not together also I've
read some lines about him and so I can
maybe piece together why but maybe she's
like sitting on a Monday night having
wine with your friends watching The
Bachelor cuz like she's a normal girl
and she sees Heather seeing her and
she's just like I just want a normal guy
like that
not someone who's like an ex boy bander
who's like on tour doing what he does
like I just want some guy from Jupiter
Florida who dances had the construction
say you want to know what done you know
no but it's like you're like why don't
you get it's like it's cool for her that
like she she literally can get anyone
she wants and like she saw so when she
liked and she went for it and like how
nice it must be to be like the most
beautiful wealthy like famous person in
the world that just like you decide you
want to go on a date with some of them
like next thing you know he's there
waiting around of date for you like it
must be nice and it's like I almost like
I I appreciate her judgment you know
we're always saying like these girls who
have everything they should just settle
down with a nice guy a businessman but I
don't appreciate her judgment wanna know
why because she had the greatest man in
the world Joe Jonas who left him
literally the worst influence ever night
job might behind literally she had the
best boyfriend in the world they were
the best couple like I was so happy for
him and so happy for her and you know
what everything works in mysterious ways
and God works in mysterious ways because
literally sophie Turner and Joe Jonas
are the best couple in the entire world
like I love them too I saw them out to
dinner no I said next time I pull a bar
like they were literally like so nice to
me like they came up and gave me a hug
it like I looked so cool with the people
that I was with like I just [ __ ] love
that wow that's amazing I love them so
much and you know what I never would
have had that moment if it weren't for
Gigi Eddie's bad judgment okay agreed I
forgot about the Joe Jonas of it all
because like he just came out smelling
like roses and I feel like she had a
really interesting dating trajectory
before that like she had really good
taste in guys like Cody Simpson hot them
together like Australian blonde like
lovefest so happy for Joe Jonas the best
guy who else did you date before uh I
think that was whatever like saying just
like I feel like was not good for her no
I agree but she's trying to get out from
under that now she was going for like
America's Sweetheart like this guy
that everyone loves in it's like she
probably watches the show and loves him
too and then wake 7 realizes like hey
I'm Gigi Hadid like why don't I go for
it no she's annoying
just have something like just it's like
this just gives me that only like people
like Tyler see well now only date people
who look like teaching right for all us
regular Joe's and he was an average Joe
right it has instilled absolutely no
confidence in the world so it's like
gigi hadid follows you you're done go
for your future bachelor contestants
it's like I don't want to win I want to
be run around I want to date Gigi Hadid
yeah why do I want to date this girl
like this girl from Alabama totally
runner-up in the pageant right naughty
she didn't even win the pad no she
wasn't even runner-up right she didn't
make top ten right the drama so I'm just
well but it's breaking the franchise in
half right if this is the greatest love
story ever told
then so be it but honestly I'm just like
I'm annoyed I think it's worse if it's
the greatest love story ever told
because then there's no hope for the
rest of us like if they had a bad time
last night and they never see each other
again like we can just chalk it up to
like maybe she's a fan wanted to meet
him like whatever right but do you think
them going to show house was their
attempt of being discreet yes because so
house is like so thirsty like everyone
there's always like looking over their
shoulders to see what famous persons I
can't take pictures like if they were at
a regular rooftop bar everyone would
have been on their phones we would have
video of you hire someone of
live-streamed it like at least if
someone wanted to get a picture of him
which they did it had to be concealed
and then I was like people were
analyzing the picture like this doesn't
look like a date like it looks like they
were checking in then checking at the
yeah I was so no yeah no but like they
were like that's not the body language
of a date like it cuz they just got
there yeah and like I don't think he's a
member I don't know if they have so how
second Jupiter yeah she was probably
checking in for him and he's very
political thing it's also like super
awkward like to go on a date like two so
I was like if you're a member and
someone's not it's like you've to sign
them in like they have to call
downstairs it's like super awkward like
it's honestly not the ideal place for a
state if you're not both members a
hundred percent and if they don't
already find a table if he got there
first
then he has to wait for her and then
they I was like hugging the entry so
other people are no painful painful and
the getting a seat I have to believe
that she's in this summer to that she
can get is a reserved yet like they hear
she's coming and they reserved a table
for her because like in this stuff I
mean all year round but especially in
the summer because it's like one of the
few places in the city with a pool it is
impossible to find a chair
let alone a table however Dumbo house is
bigger yes then meatpacking so they
probably had more options it was a
Sunday night it was chill honestly like
we should go to demo house one day like
enjoy swim also I just want to say I
ship Hannah Tyler hardcore hi damn I
like it there they could be I think he's
definitely too good just a girl Asian
being someone's runner up like you know
no questions asked like Oh Jed turned
out to be a bad guy okay I'm here I'm a
big dope I never got it all no she she
no no she didn't make a mistake she only
really made a mistake when the guys she
chose didn't end up being even remotely
good enough yeah it's like I was thing
about like re and Becca and Lauren it's
like he was the one who made the
decision to end to go back to Lauren she
had made the decision for Hanna
yeah if Jed hadn't been in a
relationship Hanna would still be it's
not like Hanna said Jed you know what
it's not working out because I love
Tyler right Tyler like Tyler was
literally the last thing left yeah Margo
still ships Hannah and Pete no I know
Petersons are a hundred percent Tyler
after all this Tyler can't be the
bachelor
honestly I surely being The Bachelor
right now I know but I were like so
disappointed if they don't choose my
Johnson oh yeah like it's time but yeah
yeah no Jo Tommy just he went to
paradise and yeah but so the Colton but
he like that's true so it looks like
he's happy Colton we thought he was
happy to tell you he left crying yeah we
didn't think he was happy no one thought
he was happy
no but like when he was going on
paradise we knew there was something
with him and Tia yeah but when he left
paradise he was single but we didn't
know that at the time my Tom said we saw
something in the toasters and it doesn't
look like he's saying it look good not
be true
honestly if I turn this off that's right
like I'll be annoyed that's also good
what if she found true love like that's
the point of being a bachelor is it
though I'd be like Colton really did
like Tia but he wanted to be the
bachelor yeah yeah that's what he was
being like so held back like that's what
he was so confused
I guess he was too if I was like up for
the role of a lifetime yeah I hear you
justice for Tia was she kind of nice man
dude she's happy um so back to the Tyler
and Gigi of it all I wonder if there
will be a second date I wonder if they
kissed if they had sex I think Oh back
to her part of my god
I just like it's annoying when you get
to know someone on reality TV cuz like
you have become accustomed like knowing
everything about their lives so it's
like Oh Tyler's on the date
normally we would see how it ends with
Hannah but says we don't know how it
ends with Gigi and that's frustrating
yeah I don't think they like spent the
night together but I don't think she'd
use that type of girl but I won I hope
it went well I'm treating for them I
just want to know Boise is one big step
for a bachelor kind even though we just
make everyone even more out of control
than they already are
do you think that like the world's
reaction to to the date like everyone
being like turn GG off to the idea of
dating someone from bachelor nation she
is like super low-key
she's low-key as much as she can be but
like she's still gigi hadid like it's
not if anyone she dates it's gonna be a
big deal no like I think the world if we
had seen her on a date with Harry Styles
whatever like a famous person I don't
think the world would have freaked out
as much as they did with with Tyler no
cuz it's crazy
yeah I agree so I'm saying do you think
that it's gonna turn her off to this
relationship I don't know I think any
relationship that is gonna be it's gonna
be super public and it's not even like
they were paparazzi so it's just people
caring like yeah that's true yes you
know like yeah that's true that's true
so I think I don't know I think it's
exciting I think it's cool
no no I'm so not here for it and I just
can't even like Joe and Sophie must be
laughing Oh laughing their way to the
bay Shirley laughing their way to
anywhere but Gigi you know because I
think when when Gigi broke up with Joe I
think when when Joe and Gigi were dating
like though he was obviously aware that
like he was dating the most beautiful
woman in the world and like that never
happens and like he knew like the the
position and then when he broke up with
her like I think he was like obviously
super devastated but like there's an
element when you're in a public
relationship it's like embarrassing
yeah and it's just like you know when
it's not about who wins but like in this
case it is and like Joe totally won
because you think when you break up with
Gigi Eddie like when you go from you
yeah you can only go down but nobody
waits you go up parrot no parallel I
don't know no I think so there's so much
like the movies like what are you
kidding women against each other but
like but here we go
no I think it was it a parallel move you
know what I think it depends who you ask
right in your type yeah do you watch
Game of Thrones if you don't want to be
thrown some you don't watch x-men who's
sophie Turner right well she wasn't
without camera in Hailee Steinfeld
barely lethal great yeah that was good
stuff I'm really just this is this in
this story in particular has deadly
reinvigorated my interest in the
franchise agreed and maybe that that was
the plan the whole time I totally agree
like I'm really excited for paradise I'm
glad I watched the first episode I know
everyone's name and profession and what
they're about I know that Luke is a
villain Jed is a villain I don't think
either of em were in paradise right and
so uh John Paul Jones John Paul Jones is
hilarious okay he's just like a funny
dude I think you know how there's always
that one who's like friends with The
Bachelor
yeah like Vinny on Jojo sees it that way
that was for Hannah Jones cool I
appreciate him and the Fergie twin that
doesn't have a boyfriend like hey dawg I
can't believe the Fergie twin is on
Paris actually they'd let me to like I
watched the intro so I was just seeing
all the people that were coming and it's
like truly like go home yeah and also I
loved him so much but also Derek path
like I was you had some dream time what
is TQ rebut he posted on Instagram I
read the first sentence and then I'm
like this captions too long for me to
read - may I please have the TLDR house
how you and he said basically that like
by the way I just learned the TLDR means
I'm like it's my whole life I don't know
what so you never read anything
she is a LDR okay so basically he said
that he was approached to on bachelor in
paradise he was wary because he's had
like these experiences in the past of
like either being portrayed in the way
that he's not we're seeing other people
that way and you know I think he had a
bet that nobody's seen what the show can
do and he left on kind of a high I would
like it's risky and also like he met the
person that he said he's gonna spend the
rest of his life with in that situation
it's just like it's weird it's weird and
but then he was saying like and probably
people that he works with wouldn't
understand and blah blah blah but you
know I think it's hard for him to meet
people in the real world because that
guy from The Bachelor and growing your
own paradise like you don't have that
stigma and maybe he can really meet
someone that's fair that's fair boy I
think that he is the perfect candidate
of someone who could like find a great
relationship in Paradise he says he's
not a thirst monster at all like he has
a full time job I wonder how we got time
off like he worked so hard he's like
very mentally stable which is V rare
these days and I agreed like any girl
would be lucky
I'm in love with him because I just and
honestly I feel like my taste in
terrified like says a lot about me like
I'm a good person
yeah well I think he's the kind of guy
that keeps a Bachelor franchise like
hello ground afloat and grounded where
it's like no there are still real good
people coming here to look for love not
everyone is coming here to promote their
music with their girlfriend right
backward and he totally enjoys all the
benefits of being on on the franchise
and the Instagram but he doesn't
that wasn't why he came and that's not
what motivates him yeah I agree
she's a good ass guy yeah it gave me
heartbeat is that why you don't win much
paradise just like Chinese TLDR to see
him no idea another woman I mean it was
hard to see him on paradise with Taylor
cuz like she sucks but like I really
appreciated how he made her like so
human yeah he just has that effect on
that MS ladies okay that was longest
first story ever I know but we talked
about like a lot I didn't talk about The
Bachelor though this whole year and
people were like up in arms about it so
I hope that gave people their bachelor
pics yeah we will be talking about
Paradise snatchler is a reality the
snatchler the podcast is real but that
would mean you have to start on
Wednesday yeah they keep lemmy's we
gotta get like cover art that means we
have to watch together
does it are you guys listening it
together well this match is hosting it
but I think four snaps are in Paradise
uh if we're all watching we should do
together okay but it's her ship so like
she can kick it's your show but what
about the card to be a guy we got to get
you all set up we could do that what the
Photoshop scene made it oh right let's
see that's a great idea that's right
okay called the snatch Larry I think
it's a great name honestly meet you and
then like people will laugh when they
hear it yeah I don't want to watch it
took the morning breath yeah yeah met
unified to released a song called breath
cuz that's see what the equivalent would
have been yeah I actually want to
release another song I was talking to
someone about it
remember had the chains burgers like did
selfie was like a joke but like kind of
real I want to do a song about like
people who need a mint you know it's
like you need it'll be like a rap you
need a man no no go out I'm high okay
you don't want to be like sophomore
slump everyone's waiting for you to fail
it's so true kiss and I won't let that
me be handing it to
done you need a mid tic-tac icebreaker
yeah they still breathe I think there's
really potential there but I'll listen
to you're right about everything always
I'll listen to you it's a tough call oh
no I think okay buddy
next story ride and Orbitz
oh my god next story Valentina sampaio
is reportedly dentine ice Victoria's
Secret's first transgender at oh by the
way maybe some pale and she looks so
much like Sara Sampaio is she don't
really did I was thinking the same thing
after that I didn't do any digging okay
in the words of my good good friend Joe
Joe it's just a little too late a little
too long and I can't wait also betray
secrets like basically grammar business
they don't have a thing anymore what is
there what work is there for the smell
to you betray secrets definitely not
going out of business it's a major major
business it's on its way town but
there's no show and there's no there's
no show so it's like this show is the
most public-facing thing like we don't
care what you guys do with your
Christmas camp would you catalog
no one's waiting like we donated breath
for the catalog in the man and the
conversation about them not being
inclusive with plus-size trans models
was about the fashion show so it's like
oh now you've decided but there's no
fashion show we don't care anymore yeah
I mean it's it's still like great but
it's a little too late like I really
feel as though Jojo was way ahead of her
time when writing that song because that
is so pertinent right now so pertinent
to the situation and I think it's great
obviously on this you know the worldwide
stage inclusivity but it's like it's
honestly what now it's like why bother
yeah and they already made their big
stink about like fantasy yeah I know
what is like ya know like that statement
was so abhorrent I honestly would have
had more respect for them if they just
stuck to that you know this is so
try-hard yes so inauthentic you know
they're not doing it because they really
feel like they want to be inclusive it's
like they just they think it's the right
thing to do because they feel bad about
what they said you know and because I
clearly what they said was completely
wrong they're no longer having a show
no one is interested in that right so
it's like a Hail Mary and but for what
ends no and it's just like the people
out there love or just like they've been
waiting for this thing that was such a
great tip of them hate to say we told
you so it's just a stupid and it's like
it's great look I'm not I'm not putting
a negative spin on it it's just it's
silly yeah it's just we've all written
them off already
yeah so this is like a last-ditch effort
at them to like attempt to join the
world in 2019 yeah they're so far behind
it's really too little and it's too late
you know just like one transgender model
and it's like after your show has been
great it's like oh okay so it's like
your house is on fire and it's like
you're pouring a bottle of water on it
yeah you know it's just truly like no
but the house has already burned to the
ground it's like don't bother don't
bother angry okay next story Camila
Cabello smacks down body shamers saying
that is beautiful that oh my god she's
the smallest girl ever like okay sorry
continue
Camila caballo to critics to task on
Saturday responding to body shamers with
an emotional message posted to Instagram
story quote I haven't gone on social
media at all with the conscious
intention of avoiding things that hurt
my feelings
my eyes accidentally ran over a headline
of people body shaming me Kibeho said
she felt super insecure initially just
imagine just imagining what these
pictures must look like oh no my
cellulite oh no I didn't suck in my
stomach but then I was like of course
there are bad pictures of course there
are bad angles my body's not made of
[ __ ] rock or all muscle for that
matter love this message but it's just
like okay we now live in a world where
Camila Kibeho gets body shamed it's like
what are they gonna say about me like
not to make it all about me but it's
just like are you crazy
like this is so nuts it's so nuts
it doesn't she's so petite she write so
like this really doesn't make me feel
good it instills very little faith in me
yeah and I have to be honest I didn't
see what pictures like or had like IBM
ends of her with Shawn Mendes in Miami
like in the ocean
the ocean they were walking and all that
okay I need to love them that's the
walking out of the ocean what is weight
of the width of the waves okay I have to
say I don't work out a lot so I don't
know what the hardest workout in the
world is but I do think that top five
hardest workouts is getting out of the
ocean it's so it's so hard I'm trying to
do it remotely gracefully is borderline
impossible like justice for Pamela
Anderson justice for Denise richer it's
like when she yes that's why she's such
an icon okay wait I'm trying to say
ocean and I also want to talk about
those pictures of them kissing is oh my
god by the way like literally not an
ounce of cellulite I'm so crazy
what no this is so like it must be at
the wrong picture that can't be it no
she's wearing the white bathing suit
yeah
how stupid Wow um can we talk just such
a great Bobby pictures have been making
out of Miami yeah I'd like to read body
language because I feel as though I'm a
body language expert and just from what
I'm seeing based on like the kissing the
leaning in she's definitely more into
him than he is into her but I have now
come to the fully I have fully confirmed
with myself that it's definitely a real
relationship oh you think so cuz when I
saw the pictures of them like kissing in
a way that looked like they didn't
realize people were watching cuz it was
like not the cutest kiss it was very
open mouth it was yeah it was very cute
when I saw just the photo I was like oh
wow that's so real cuz that's a real
kiss like if it was fake would be yeah
um but then I saw the video and maybe he
was just like distracted but then I
think if it was a fake relationship he
would be acting yeah that's why I said
she definitely looks I think it's
definitely a real relationship and in
every relationship like especially ones
that don't last forever someone is
always obviously more into the one than
the other
no in every relationship when you're
like kissing in the Miami Heat in a pool
and in the ocean like it's possible that
someone's not into it
no I mean if you literally paparazzi me
in bed like all hours of the day like
you would think we were getting divorced
because I'm probably telling at him like
I'm always pushing him away from me like
it's just such as life ya know if you
photographed me and Zach on the beach in
Miami you wouldn't be able to get a
photo of the two of us no it's so Jenna
like myspace so so I don't like the body
language is not a perfect formula
because you
can't know what's going on in the moment
and again I always try and think of like
it when it my head and it just like even
if somewhat limited paparazzi doesn't
bed last night like I was literally
stopping him like you would think he was
in an abusive ever when you're in bed
like think of your body language didn't
think about what an expert would say no
but you know what I do do do do
when me and Ben are walking on the
street like holding hands I always
pretend like I would be paparazzi that
I'm like I literally defined it like
this is such a cute paparazzi picture
and then I like act like as if I'm a
real celebrity and like we are getting
paparazzi didn't it's like the five
minutes of the day where we actually get
along oh that's cute yeah that's really
cute know whenever like we're sometimes
in bed in weird positions and like what
would a body language experts say about
what are the positions like something
like either like this and this doesn't
mean that you're in a fight it's like no
I'm comfortable enough with you to tell
you what I want it might mean I couldn't
agree more and but you have a queen-size
bed yeah so even when you're on separate
sides you're really not that far at
least one part of our epidermis is
always touching so that's what me and
Ben is like in bed of a king-size bed
and we could not be further apart from
each other at all times but our feet are
always touching yeah and you're always
touching theosis Co is like the bridge
that connects our two souls
he's the transmitter yes yeah like
sometimes but also there is an element
to body language experts said that is
total [ __ ] Oh most of it it's like
you [ __ ] know when you go to college
for your body language degree no totally
and I love with like you know magazines
like sight body language experts like as
if they're true professionals like I
don't think a body language expert can
hold up in a court of law you know much
like a polygraph test
right that was so crazy I mean I just
caught up on me on guys in Beverly Hills
when they said that it was her second
time going and she tweeted she's like
Kat was but I needed to film it was like
they weren't lying about that I didn't
think they were lying but I never
thought she would admit it she's and
you're an LBP san at this point which I
never thought any of you were I thought
it was just like thoughts um but if you
really are like you need it oh wait
sorry I've literally ran LBP Stan at
this point still no I know like I truly
it's kind of how when Carolyn Bethenny
were going through the thing we wanted
to have like an official debate because
I couldn't get into the mindset of
someone who was supporting Carolyn okay
but actually I couldn't get into their
mindset but I saw what it was in the
equal you know it was a debate it was
you could argue both sides there is no
this point after the reunion I still
even want the season was happening I
understood how you know someone could
see someone who loves LVP couldn't see
maybe she's been wronged I don't agree
with it but I could see it after this
reunion like everything that's coming
out the fact that she doesn't even show
up I can't even defend herself and
everything that she said in the past
that contradicts what she's saying now
and like the patterns like there's just
no she really should have showed up and
left like literally the last ounce of
respect that I had for her was gone the
second cheetah chopper reunion are you
serious [ __ ] like you have been
absolutely adamant about holding every
single person on that couch accountable
for things they've done over the years
and things they said it's like now it's
your turn I'm like you can't handle the
heat you are such a [ __ ] honestly
you're such a [ __ ] like it's so
frustrating and she like deemed herself
like the queen of Beverly Hills like she
was in charge of this troop and it's
like you're just gonna like not show up
like you [ __ ] coward coward also I
had a lot of respect for Camille for
going because one she's it was not easy
she's an entire cast member so she
didn't go it wouldn't be such a big deal
and she like wouldn't have to go through
the ringer but she's like I didn't agree
with what she was saying what she was
doing but she sat there and she took it
and she took a lot of stuff released
because she was just the only
representation and at one point I like
kind of felt what she was saying when
she was like sometimes I'm with you guys
and I feel what you're saying and then
I'm with Lisa and I and I feel like I'm
that way a lot of ya know being a people
pleaser but all they were all they were
saying it's just like oh like you are so
convincing when you're with us and then
we're just like so confused when you see
something else I totally get that too
and I don't feel like you have to bash
like the other side to get along with
the other side you can't be firmly in
the middle yeah but she was Camille was
in I mean uh Denise was in the middle
for a really long time Camille was just
so bad at being in the middle that she
was confusing everyone around her yeah
but she sat there she took it she
apologized like she was moving the walk
off of a lifetime with her tits out
right she had moments of humanity and
then at the end when like they really do
have anything left to say and she was
like today I'm sorry if I hurt your
feelings like did she [ __ ] hurt her
feelings I'm like now I'm like oh you're
Camille yeah you're trash pernicious as
hell also like don't don't [ __ ] come
for Denise Richards like she was being
so mean to Denise bye guys
literally no reason but I feel like she
was started off being meet her because
Annie was like
them against each other so Andy was like
hyper involved in this reunion and no
one that was like a fight that no one
was looking for yeah like women editors
edited because also did you see donation
on watch happens I've no she was cleared
she was she was that cooktop moving like
it she was like between this weird thing
with her arm it was a great episode she
must see Titus and watch what happens
live we did a whole deep dive okay I
would actually like it is Mike [ __ ]
cross Tamara because I'm so torn because
I literally live breathing die for Titus
and Ramadan but also like Andy is my
father so but I gotta say in geminon is
not Titus Burgess and he doesn't want
you to forget that no literally never do
you know that I met him I met him too
and I know what you're talking him yeah
I asked them to do Pinot Noir and he was
like no he was sober and it was like
after season it was in the same way it
was season when I was a college yeah no
I was there he is like it's so crazy
he's must be such a good actor because
he is literally the him himself his
personality is the antithesis of Titus
and Ramadan but still quiet so reserved
pullback like not into himself at all
yeah so what did you think about that
did you watch the episode I watched the
episode after having read about the
drama and I saw like Titus was just
being so shady and like we just hard on
Andy which I it was just it was weird
and there were too many games in the
episode like he was just I think he
didn't know I didn't require a statement
like I didn't think no I thought Andy's
question was fair too I thought Titus
answered fairly yeah we could have left
it at that
no totally he got like so butt hurt and
upset in the moment like visibly like
when they went to commercial break he
like got up I went to the bar yeah and
then he just like he made it into
anything else Oh spoke about it on Wendy
Williams like he just he's like riding
this wave like he wanted to start drama
yeah but after the house it wasn't as
egregious of a thing as he made it out
to be you know but he was obviously he
got upset at first but like and II don't
remember that the play thing it's like
are you kidding me nes ii guess every
day for the past few years he probably
I'm out a year ago and told him that
like sorry they didn't remember that
you're working on a play that's still
hasn't come out yet like I thought that
was really like entitled of him I agree
and it's a poor Laverne Cox just like
being the glamorous Queen that she is
like having to sit in the middle of his
trash she was amazing she she has
amazing touch the show oh I do so
I'm just I'm kind of unfamiliar with her
working like I was so impressed by her
and her love of housewives yes you know
she first of all I love when a celebrity
comes on and there's a Bravo superfan it
makes the episode so much better and
she's just truly like grace and elegance
and fun though yeah and I was like
really enjoyed that like her episode got
dragged to the mud I want her back on
alone because like she her watch happens
live experience like was tainted with
this trash yes she's no above it she
should be on with the housewife yeah I
think she said uh yeah that would be
awesome yeah okay um this is kind of a
story from last week that's still
ongoing and confusing and I don't think
we've spoken about it you ever Brody
Jenner and Kaitlyn harder breakup they
were never legally married but just like
I tried a new thing that everyone's
doing like getting married but like not
legally I think it's a California thing
I think it's a money thing yeah
in California thing because getting
married with money in California is
apparently like so unappealing it's very
irresponsible because people in
California never see married for long
and everything in California is
community property so if you're married
for five minutes you split your
everything I'm kind of here for it for
them for these people yeah no now it's
not messy and it's so self-aware of them
it's like everyone in Hollywood gets
divorced five minutes later like let's
just get married like fake yeah I don't
really know much about her
um and I remember the last time we spoke
about her I said that I was almost about
to follow her on Instagram and I have
officially thought her and I think she's
such a precious gem woman she's
literally looking girl I've ever seen
she's a businessman beau like I think
she's a businesswoman
oh you think yeah it's just
disappointing because like I feel like
I've known Brody Jenner for so long you
know and it's like we all kind of grew
up together and say now I'm married it's
like they could indeed avril lavigne
right and it's like okay we all grew up
together like now it's your turn like
Spencer's married like I thought this
was it yeah you know and she seemed to
get along great with the family like and
she's like cool enough to keep up with
his lifestyle but like but low-key
enough to ground him yeah so I don't
know anything about that my gesture
probably some photos but it's it's
disappointing because now he's gonna be
like again let go to the Palms like
looking up was Lauren like yeah but it's
like even Frankie's married yeah so I
don't know but like she'll be fine
they'll both be fine but sad I actually
like when I heard they got married I'm
like this is it it is weird that though
he was married to a woman who has the
same
as Caitlyn Jenner ya know now there's
just one Caitlyn I'm sure Caitlin's
pleased yeah it's like less confusing at
dinner now yeah it's like ah Stephen
didn't go to the wedding didn't she I
don't know no the Jenner's are like love
to like not show up at important family
moments you know days yeah Rob wasn't at
Kim and Kanye's wedding I mean Brody
wasn't at Kim's wedding because he
didn't get a date for Caitlyn and it was
cable because Kim was like I don't know
that this girl's gonna stick around I
don't need her at my wedding and I mean
I guess now she was proving right but
she should have been there because they
did get married but I totally feel that
sentiment 100% like you were very loose
at your wedding I remember just like
talking to you before you're writing
about like ring ring thing I was like
very very adamant about not like me and
didn't have a lot of similar friends so
it's like I was friends with the girl
and Ben was tense with a guy and they
were together like it made it a lot
easier but it's like if we're friends
it's one of them and like it's a new
girlfriend like honestly know which I'm
sure a lot of people like were mad at me
about but I don't care I didn't really
have any sticky situations and if I did
it was like one or two and in which case
if it's one or two more people and it's
gonna make someone if someone's coming
in from out of town like and it's just
gonna make their experience better
whatever yeah no I was a little bit more
so I feel Kim on that front
oh for sure also she's Kim right it's
like literally it's 150 person wedding
like not plus ones were just not doled
out no I totally agree so I know I
thought this was kind of shocking crazy
that they were never even married but I
guess that makes things like super clean
ya know it's like literally just move
out who gets the dog have you watched
the hills at all no and I'm really like
I'm I'm I'm so pleased with that
decision like there were moments when I
didn't watch a batterer we're like you
know I saw things I'm like oh mom
Margaret said it was good like you know
my heart was like did I make the wrong
decision
I feel no regrets absolutely no regrets
about not watching the hills like I've
actually never been in a better place
you know yeah emotionally physically
well not physically but you know what I
mean
speaking of the hills Mischa Barton EOC
rachel Bilson did you see that maybe
she's fading the file
what no sneaking flirty on Instagram I
was funny on Instagram a January Jones
and like the deadly hugs yes yeah I
don't think that they are dating but
yeah you were gonna say rachel bilson
cashews reunited with George and Wade
last night while posted votes Heart of
Dixie
yeah from our to fixate where they
whatever whoever George his real name is
in real life he like had some show or
something and yes oh she's play with
Mona
yeah I'm pretty little I know that isn't
everything yes she Alice's a great
[ __ ] manager everyone showed up and
[ __ ] I met her she was so nice Wow let's
do it all
truly yeah I love her like being nice
these days it's like an anomaly you know
yeah it's like you used to be gossip
it's like oh my god I met Hilary Duff
she was so mean now it's like it's more
interesting to find out his eyes yeah I
feel like somebody's have caught on to
that like I feel like every interview
I've ever read with Gigi Hadid she's
like talks about how nice she is to
people on set that's what she talks
about her McDonald's came on our show
she did a whole bit a hundred percent
she always says that she's like my mama
always used to tell me when I was
younger growing up to be nice to
everybody by the way that's Kris Jenner
Kris Jenner no I'm like I believe that
but every single injury she's ever done
go look at it she talks about being nice
on set and that is histor just other
people are supposed to say that about
you you're not gonna say it about
yourself Heather McDonald said that
every article she reads about
celebrities like the writer always makes
it a point to be to mention how kind the
actress was to the waiter you know it's
like Congrats we do that too why is that
noteworthy in Men's Fitness Magazine
right also if they're not gonna be kind
to the waiter in front of a journalist
right like that's bad yeah then they're
out of control
yeah so we talked about so congrats you
saw your head screwed who is the nicest
and mean a celebrity you've ever met ooh
um I you have viously have your answer
lined up I know I mean I'll leave the
meanest one because honestly triggered
me like from a write off yeah yeah also
like it's up there Titus Burgess like he
was so rude to me and I was an intern
and I was like so nervous and like he
just like took advantage of like it was
just no like I was just I was so
vulnerable like he was a celebrity
I was the intern like I had to ask him
something and like he said no which I
get so pain to say no but like he said
in like the most derogatory way like it
was really upsetting I think the nicest
subber day I've ever met is Peter Herman
Oh honestly
yeah you know I'm gonna go off of toast
guess cuz I can't think of just celebs
that I've met in my life
um and when people come here like they
should be nice so if they even mean like
then that's weird yeah
Peter Herman's definitely up there yeah
I can't even I don't even I don't even
know like if you meet someone at a party
and they're not nice to you like they're
there at a party like when you guys met
james Van Der Beek and you
she's gonna be on the street oh he was
not he did not want to be chased like we
were being freaks and this he was with
his kids and his wife like in Saturday
and we were like there were stalkers
coming for him did he let you take a
picture yes yeah happy about it that's
nice though a lot of celebrities say no
I've been seeing in the toaster group
just like pictures of different
celebrities that toasters run into and
they asked them for a picture and they
say like not right now like not they say
it really nice but they they blatantly
say no yeah I'm fine think that's fine
it's they got to be off duty I guess
yeah yeah yeah no we were so weird about
James interview literally like a brand
we're like where's do you think you've
been the weirdest I think I've been the
absolute weirdest on multiple occasions
in front of Brett Eldredge like each
time I meet him I'm like a little drunk
and like like horny for him and I like
make him kiss me like I'm a freak and
every picture is so ugly I've never even
posted because I get my celebrity smile
I get my celebrity chin and I just said
gets so weird and I like so I make
myself a freak and I never even get
content out of it like I met him three
times and both all times I have made him
kiss me I mean I'm I'm I always act as a
fan like I can't not and in situations
where like you're not supposed to be the
fan so that I don't even look at them I
pretend that they're not there like this
yeah yeah that's what I feel like we did
that recently and I remember what it was
oh yeah okay I remember when we were
saying when we were at the Taylor so
thing and Gigi was there like no kiddin
look her way yeah yeah we was really
awkward we can't be like oh yeah when I
went to a Halloween party in LA I was
just like literally talking to Sarah
silver in and I was just like I you
don't have to pretend like you don't
even know what they do actually
sometimes ignorance is bliss because
probably the most famous person I've
ever met I was sitting next ready
general party and I had no idea who he
was a dreamer Nate Adrien Brody and
we're just talking and I'm like what do
you do and he gave me a weird face and
then he's like I'm a painter oh that's
so cool where can I see your stuff and
then after I left someone told me that
it was Adrien Brody I'm like I was
sitting next to the pianist
like literally arguably the most
impactful piece of Jewish work ever and
I didn't know yeah he'll be better I
would've been afraid but then sometimes
I feel like you meet people and it's
like I really I don't follow your work
and I know who you are but I'm really
not a fan but
feel like you should say like I love
your work where cuz you'd want to be
rude but you also it's so it's so dumb
and each celebrity is so different like
some people live to be recognized and
some people want like nothing to do they
just really want to be normal
yeah so you use your judgement
especially with real summaries like not
reality to get your reality TV people
love to be recognized and that's a cheat
code and because it's their real life
you know it's not so crazy to talk about
right but when you're talking about a
character that they probably like didn't
even like playing but like Adrian Brody
was such a good actor I didn't even
recognize his true self
yeah interesante no I'm the worst around
famous people like I guess so I don't
even have a shower ah flustered yeah
it's just like they're just people you
guys you know so weird
no I think I don't want to ask for a
picture because it's just so we and then
it makes it weird afterwards the x-men
it's like oh this girl's a fan like I
have to have my car back yeah yeah yeah
okay
didn't final story a little business I
don't know if it's business been a
little aviation news United pilots
arrested accused of intoxication prior
to us bound flight from the UK oh my god
it's the Denzel Washington I saw like
two United Airlines pilots were arrested
at Glasgow Airport in Scotland on
Saturday morning after allegedly failing
a breath test prior to boarding a flight
bound for Newark New Jersey wait so they
have to breathalyze before every flight
I guess so I mean they should yeah yeah
please set police Scotland said the men
aged 45 and 61 were being held under
Transportation Safety law that covers
on-the-job intoxication and impairment
for aviation the flight was canceled
that [ __ ] sucks
oh okay listen it land and then they
realized I got the breathalyzer results
too late in Scotland oh no the flight
was cancelled because they were thought
to like Newark like this could've been
oh I'm sure we know someone on that
plate that oh my god that absolutely
sucks and like imagine if like you're
waiting you're delayed finding out but
the reason like when it's like [ __ ] out
of your control like mechanical whatever
it's like it's so frustrating but it's
like us just literally had one job and
it was to show up sober yeah but do you
think it was like from last night yeah
they said that they yeah I read an
article and it was like they showed up
still drunk ooh what a night it's even
worse but why would they be like ripping
shots in the morning right so I don't
know the whole thing
is weird do you ever see there would be
flight yes no could I tell you ever
gonna see it I don't know should I
it's actually pretty good no I don't
think you like it so the premise of the
movie is since I watched him it's like
this super like seasoned amazing pilot
but he has like a little bit of a
problem you know so the movie starts he
wakes up in the morning does a line of
cocaine and gets on the plane and he
gets on the plane and they're not
serving alcohol because the turbulence
but he grabs two little things of vodka
chugs em and throw them in the trash the
plane's engine fails both of them fails
and he has the ingenious idea to flat
drop all the gas into the ocean and fly
the plane upside down something so
everyone gets in their seat in their
seatbelts except for one kid and the kid
is like bopping around because he's not
in a seat belt but everyone else is
upside down and he lands the plane like
on a field he like into a church like
literally one person died the kid
because didn't put his [ __ ] seatbelt
on and obviously everyone's in the house
while they take his blood they see at
alcohol they saw no alcohol was served
on the plane but there's two alcohol
things in the trash so now the whole
thing comes about like he did kill one
person but he saves 300 other people but
he was intoxicated like could he have
done but so and he's like going through
this trial while being a complete
[ __ ] alcoholic like he can't say he
can't stop showing up to the trials
drunk but like all of his lawyers are
just trying to so whatever like I won't
tell you how it ends up happening but
it's such an interesting like is that a
thing if you fly the plane upside down I
don't know like he was he was like a
Sully like I really like had a real like
intuition for yeah instinct for planes
interesting that's great though yeah
just to recount it better the kids
parents with the seatbelt yeah I don't
remember but like the flight attendant
got up out of her seat belt to try and
get the kid like it was so dramatic and
I watched a movie like right before
going on a plane it's like it's really a
terrorizing the the actual event is such
a big portion of the movie that it's
like [ __ ] traumatizing yeah damn okay
well those were the Fast Five stories we
have much to recap still though because
Mitch and I watch descendants three um
for the few of these that keep up with
the sentence but for most of you who
probably are kids watch descendants Oh
Jackie before you go into the sentence I
would be absolutely remiss rebuttal and
devastated if I don't let you know that
stays episode is also brought to you I
wouldn't want you to be rebuttal right
bye hello fresh healthy fresh Americans
never 1 BLK it get easy season
peace and pre-measured ingredients
delivered right to your door all you
have to do is cook and enjoy hellofresh
makes cooking delicious meals at home a
reality regardless of your comfort in
the kitchen as someone who was a very
low comfort level in the kitchen I have
found hello fresh to be quite relaxing
the lack of preparation is what makes it
so much easier guys just find that like
cooking take 6 hours because you have to
like cut up everything and like
hellofresh makes it so easy they package
everything they give me the perfect
amount of ingredients and it's really
premium you could say goodbye to endless
grocery store trips and take-out food
because hellofresh has you covered break
out your dinner rut break out of your
dinner rub with their 17th seasonal chef
curated recipes each week there's
something for everyone from family
recipes to calorie smart and vegetarian
and fun menu series like Hall of flame
Hall of Fame and craft burgers I know
you got the vegetarian one I love the
vegetarian one like all of a sudden I'm
making enchiladas and that's why it's so
crazy could do vegetarian enchiladas
mm-hmm edie extra meals to your weekly
order as well as yummy sides like a
garlic bread and cookie dough snitch on
the garlic bread do they serve CHS on
the garlic bread I mean it doesn't say
in my notes but I'll have to ask you
could probably add your own sneech s
which is the right size you can like
have some eyes and make it your own so
it all gets delivered to your house you
can change your delivery days super
easily you can change your food press
preferences and you could skip a week if
need be
so for 80 dollars off your first month
of hellofresh
go to hello fresh comm slash toast 80
and enter the code toast 80 again that's
hello fresh comm slash toast 80 it's
like receiving eight meals free or $20
off your first four boxes it's it's
really worth a it's really and I've
heard a lot of feedback from toasters
about this brand in particular that
they've really just improved our lives
the time the prep the money because
grocery stores are so expensive I really
can't recommend enough I said I said
wemmick in debt and I just can't run
can't is enough you know what I can't
ramekins descending sorry I know I can't
oh I think were gonna say yeah I can't
recommend living because we were so
excited descendants 1 & 2 likewise
Randall for having a party watching
descended you guys can come and it would
you not we invited you kidding of here
you're begging you to come
but I'm so glad I didn't first let him
watch the stupid-ass movies and I'm so
glad it was bad because I didn't miss
out oh yeah he said I wanted to you
should be you should watch one inch ooh
they're so good three was just it was
not it first not it the story the plot
was just not good
here's what's so weird the one of the
main characters in the third movie was
someone who wasn't even asked to be back
in the second movie
yeah they kicked her out of the frame
right here and then they brought her
back in and made her like the main
villain weird so the storyline like
didn't make sense
every time they broke into song it was
so weird and badly transitioned like I
was physically cringing yeah it was it
was not good it was not gonna die the
end mouths wig was blue when she's
purple haired and you know what it made
me think I feel like they were trying to
tie her together with her spoiler alert
father like they could be related like
now but I mean she's blue haired but
Evie's blue haired so you can't do that
he's exactly it was so it was honestly
scoop and not even that like okay
transitions were bad but the songs
weren't even good and the sounds are
always good for the play is the trilogy
/ - yes okay so like you guys will stop
leaving me out yeah you should really
watch what I do I'm good no because no
the way that it ended was like the
perfect way for it to end knowing that
that's I won't spoil like what happens
in the end but knowing that that's
what's gonna happen you know yeah they
could have done so much more you know
hundred percent it was just it was i
Kenny Ortega like usually always brings
it he's always brought it like this just
wasn't this wasn't it time for him to
retire he's been up for a long time you
can always count on him for a great Cory
cat choreographed huge number which
there were some of there were some but
like it just wasn't I guess it makes
sense cuz usually the sequel sucks and
then third brains at home but the sequel
was amazing yeah like arguably better
than the first so one of them had to
stink this was it
also not gonna lie it was there was
something spooky about watching you know
Cameron knowing yeah what happens and
they did a lot of tributes to him and
the end but it's just inside yeah that's
watch it's sad so so it was it over
before it's over now because Cameron
Boyce's nobody was always gonna be the
dessert
I was gonna be the last one okay yeah
and like you and for us who like would
never say that anything that we love is
that you are like that queen of like
standing things and even when they're
bad but you pretend to like it because
you're just such a really good stand yes
so we were so excited for this movie
like you were gonna go is good or bad
think about how bad it had to be for us
to come on the show and try I'd trash it
yeah Wow
chucking shot yeah and I don't know Ken
the blue egg like she's [ __ ] molasses
in purple and her face changes so much
in each man they flashed back to the
first the first descendant in this one
and her face is it's a different person
you know what I couldn't stop thinking
about they flashback they did a song and
they did flashbacks to the first and
second movie and then they were flashing
act his stuff in the third movie that
had happened like not unit it's the war
it was so stupid it's like we didn't
forget that this happened we're watching
with you like with it that really pisses
me off
also her acting don't count really I
love her so much so for me to say
something negative it hurts me but it
was not it's a video is sometimes you
just do the best with the material
you're given you know yeah and her lips
like you've got bigger in every scene
Wow it was crazy she really looks like
so different than what she did and I
just can't believe they that on Disney
Channel and that's just how [ __ ] up
this industry is that they like let they
will happily flashback to movie one no
lips timbre 3 with big lips and let kids
think that that's a normal thing and
that's how you just grow up yeah so like
of course kids are gonna be like that
didn't happen to me like I want lips now
like right I just I'm so here for people
getting lips to like they just act like
it's I really naturally got the Sabrina
carpenter up at all because she was like
one of Disney's finest and she just
really kind of moved on from it in like
a healthy way like she doesn't all music
now she's not it it the boy meets girl
thing got canceled but like she didn't
do anything else like she really like
escaped with her life yes she really did
it's so rare it's so rare and now she's
like a super successful music career
yeah with that Disney fan base which is
like the best fan base yeah yeah she did
it right she did she the best character
on Boy Meets Girl she wasn't the main
character she was like the cool friend
the cool friend who's always coming in
through the window yeah yeah yeah she
really had like an ideal situation like
a set up on yeah I know she plays that
like z100 Jingle Ball like she's really
like she's a great level of thing
because it's like she has fun she gets
to do cool things tons of fans um but a
lot of people probably still don't
her and like she could go to a club yep
and not be annoyed or people taking
pictures of her yeah yeah I just think
she's so interesting well but if she
wanted like a date with Tyler see she
could also get that yeah yeah but she
also could probably is cool enough to
get it so ass membership you know yeah
and maybe like she could be the
Bachelorette if she wanted to be that
she could do whatever the world is her
oyster I wouldn't be surprised if gigi
hadid lost her membership you because of
this because they're like weird about
you're not allowed to be too famous like
Kim Kardashian is not allowed to be a
member
yeah but if she didn't want to be cool
and elevated and elite but they don't
want to be famous agree but there's
something about those girls first of all
I think does membership is probably like
friends with these people yeah and
there's something about like her and
Kendall where like they they're as
low-key as they could possibly be yeah
especially when they're in New York
that's true yeah and they do know so ass
loves famous people they don't like
reality TV people and that's why Kim's
not a member no house remember no
problem people are members yeah because
they don't like reality TV but they love
celebrities and that's why you can't
take pictures because they have a no
approach rule where they wouldn't have
that rule say that these are very good
discrepancy took the word right out of
my mouth okay
well what else I caught up on below deck
this weekend I didn't um the seasons the
seasons good I just feel like the boat
is so [ __ ] sloppy like I don't know
if last episode I was like what he's
coming on you know I know and it's like
they it's really crazy that people big
guests on the show actually pay real
money yeah because it's like if you were
paying for that trip like it should be
so much more elevated like they can
never get their [ __ ] together the food
is being made by someone who literally
has never cooked a day in her life like
it's [ __ ] trash and I finished the
queen of Versailles episode I didn't is
she coming
oh she's supposed to be coming on the
show yeah I'm so I'll follow up next
week but I need to talk to her because I
hiked as because she did like if I
hadn't seen on below deck I never go on
hikes on like trips or anything I
wouldn't have I woke up early that's how
you choose because I was like if it was
on Bravo and the queen of Versailles did
it like I could do it totally I mean
they'll be cool and like it was
literally happening this week on Bravo
so I was like I have to go Claudia it
was the hardest [ __ ] thing I ever did
in my life I literally almost heard her
crying like it was just all steps and
nothing good comes from hikes but I just
like I
none of it was worth it like if you're
ever contemplating hiking guys just
don't do it don't and you see all the
southern charm kids we're in the
Hamptons this weekend hanging out with
the below tech girls Oh cute yeah really
cute about summer house did they throw
them a bone no I don't think so I didn't
see any crossover content it was a list
Bravo yeah it was it was good shows only
okay well that concludes our show for
today thank you guys so much for
watching the Millennial morning show the
morning toast we go live Monday to
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so make sure to subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up if you're
watching on YouTube but if you're
listening as a podcast we are available
anywhere podcasts can be down so it's
Spotify iTunes stitcher all the places
where my son can also be found it's
called toast streaming on Spotify iTunes
anywhere you want to thank you so much
for staying with us today it has been an
absolute pleasure joy honor to be your
host it has been have a great day we
will see you tomorrow
you need a man
you